drop your weapon you first drop it
I know you're human how because if you
were one of them you wouldn't shot me
already
at 1:07 a.m. the Odyssey satellite
received images of an unfamiliar object
moving past Mars
it stopped 250 miles above the earth and
is now orbiting our planet we called
them the others
they want earth that's the reason out
here castle I need the earth first it
took our power throwing the world into
chaos
then they took our city's laying
everything to waste
next they took our lives
with an unstoppable airborne buyers
worst of all they took control the
others were already among us
exterminating anyone and survived the
others are readying themselves for the
fifth way they had the ability to
inhabit human hosts and control their
actions they look just like us what we
do now be there for each other we can't
trust anyone anymore I was supposed to
fight the others I don't know what they
are
you were ready for the end of the world
gotta get my brother
I'll get you there
you'll know anything about it the others
to sin and I'm gonna go get in look like
a simultaneous attacks on the last night
2000 areas the 5th wave succeeds
humanity will be wiped from the face of
the earth
the other see our hope as a weakness but
they're wrong this is our home they will
not possess it